ううん。。。
緊張する
いつものポスターがないんだ
やっぱこの部屋にはこれがないと始まんねえよ
こんにちは、はじめしゃちょーです
えー
お久しぶりです
w
やば、もうね、なんか
あの、動画を撮る感覚忘れてて
戸惑うね。
非常に戸惑うんですけど、まあ
今日の動画で僕が何を言いたいかと言いますと
まあ、一ヶ月半ぐらい休んでたんですけども
動画を休止してた一ヶ月半の中でも
いろんなことがありました
で皆さんも
休止中に僕何してたか
多分
気になると思うんで
ていうわけで今日は
僕が休止中だった一ヶ月半の間にに起きた
僕が驚いたことランキングBest３
を発表しようと思います
っよ！
ぱち。。
拍手。。。
してもいいのかな。。w
拍手することでもないな
やば！むず！
俺どういうテンションで動画撮ればいいの！？
っえ、むずいむずいむずい
拍手するのでないのはわかるが
よくわかんないけど。。。
発表するね。
はい、というわけで第3位
まあこれは休止中というか
復帰した瞬間だったんですけども
チャンネル登録者が５００万人行きました。。。
ありがとうございます！
素直に喜んでいいかわかりません。
んー
なんかなぁ
不思議な気持ちですね
復帰した瞬間チャンネル登録者数がすごい増えて
あのー
嬉しい気持ち半分不安な気持ち半分でございました。
んーでも
すごいいろんな人が
見てくださっているんだなと思って
今後も頑張っていこうと思いました。
本当にありがとうございます！！
いや、やばいでしょ
復活した瞬間５００万人はやばいでs
第2位！！
応援してくれている男の子からのメッセージ
というか手紙が届きまして
ここにあるんですけども
ちょっと見て行きましょう一緒に
いや本当ありがたいよ
サインくださいってやつです
書いてあげたいんだけど
こういうの書くとみんなに書かないといけなくなるから
今回は書かないんですけど
直接僕の家に届けるというより
事務所とかに送ってもらえた方がありがたいでございます
でもわざわざありがとね本当に
（手紙の内容）
何回か書き直した跡がありますね
この子愛知県から手紙を送ってくれてて
やめないで欲しいと思って送ってくれて僕は純粋に嬉しかったです
ありがとうございます。
で、もう一枚来てます
（手紙の内容）
ここに僕がサイン書くところがありますね
そらちぃさん
。。。
まあまあ
ついでにそらちぃもまあいいやみたいな
ついでにサインもらっとこうかなみたいな
という感じで書いたんでしょうね
わざわざ僕のために手紙書いてくれて
本当にありがとうございま
この手紙をヒカキンさんに届けて
サインをもらって
ヒカキンさんにこの手紙を
戻してもらってください！
僕んちに
切手よろしくお願いします！
かえりの
ヒカキンさんのサイこ
ヒカキンさんのサイコが一番この、
書く場所が小さいっていう
ほっこりするようなことも実はありました
続きいきましょう、第１位
第１位はですね
いや、僕もすごいなと思いましたよ
すごいと言うか、ね、もうなんか
うわっ、まじかっていう感じだったね
荷物はこっちに置いてあるんですけども
はい、ここに置いてあるの全部でございます
これ何かと言うと
僕の住所に代引きで
知らない人から荷物..が届けられて
ひょっとしたら何か頼んでたっけって思って
軽い気持ちで受け取ったらすごい量だったんすよ
知らない人から僕んち宛に代引きで
荷物が送られてきたのがこちらでございます
すげー数送られてきてるんですけども
こちらです
ギュッ！と圧縮、牛フン堆肥
はい、という訳でこれだけの量の牛糞が
代引きでイタズラで送られてきました
何円だっけな、確か
４万円ぐらいだったと思います
なんで受け取ったんだろう
牛糞４万円分
届いて僕がお金を払いました
で、これに関してなんですけども
これはさすがにやべーと思って
僕、アマゾンに電話したんですよ
アマゾンに電話して、もう、その
あの大量の牛糞送ってきた人の
住所も完全に分かっております
多分これ僕が迷惑
僕が迷惑ですけどね、
僕も迷惑なんですけども
どっちかって言うとアマゾンさんとか
僕が頼んでいない牛糞を代引きで
わざわざ届けた配達業者さんとかが
その人たちの方に迷惑がかかっているので
僕は今回動画で撮りたいと思ったんで
返品せずにお金払って受け取っちゃったんですけども
もしこれ何かあると言うと
僕から連絡が行くというより
多分そちらから連絡が行くと思いますので
そういうことはしないでいただきたいと思っております
来た瞬間、今後も来るんだろうなと思って
代引きの受け取りを全部拒否して
何か送っても僕の方には今
届かないようになっております
いやあ
本当それぐらいです
僕がうわっ！てなったのは
これぐらいだったんですけれども
まあ、たまに街で誰かに見かけられたりすると
はじめしゃちょー頑張ってください
復活待ってます、応援してますっていう
お言葉をたくさんいただけて
僕は嬉しかったです
はい、こんな感じです、僕のお休み中は
うーん
あの牛糞どうしよう
も↑や↓も↑や↓も↑や↓も↑や↓も↑や↓も↑や↓も↑や↓も↑や↓
もぉ↑　や↑し↑サ↑ラ↓ダ↓
も↓や↓し↓もぉ↑　や↑し↑い↑た↓め↓
も↓や↓し↓の↑　ア↓イ↓ス↓　ク↓ー↑リ↓ー↑ム↓
も↑や↓も↑や↓も↑や↓も↑やっ↓
もっ！もっ！やっ！しっ！♬
はじめん！頑張ってください！！